une passe aujourd'hui à sur notre petit
écran il a 15 ans et évolue déjà au
niveau national qui élit ce very permet
aux yvelines d'être représenté au
championnat de france de break dance
c'est le 18 novembre prochain dans le
nord pas de calais une aventure pour ce
jeune sportif accompli avec surtout
derrière le soutien indéfectible de sa
famille et sujet de marylène iapichino
et nicolas landry des étirements de la
concentration et des prises de notes à
l'âge de 15 ans kelis prend ses
entraînements au sérieux l'enjeu est de
taille il est qualifié pour le
championnat de france de breakdance
alors pour être prêt la stratégie est
bien rodée au début de l'entraînement je
mets mes sont à moi que j'ai dans ma
playlist
je mets au hasard et en fait après au
milieu de l'entraînement je vais sur
youtube et je mets des sons que je
connais pas pour que je puisse m'habitue
à danser sur différents styles de fond
parce que ça va pas toujours être le
même sens
cette discipline il la partage avec
toute sa famille quand les coaches ne
sont pas là ce sont ses frères nos
soeurs eux-mêmes breakdancer qu'il
corrige ses gestes avec une grande
publicité
c'est vrai qu'on nous dit souvent qu'on
est lié on a souvent des crottes pour se
motiver et puis ne training ils sont
faut savoir qu'ils sont jamais vraiment
vraiment sérieux en général on fait
toujours un peu les qu'on en fait on est
lié et c'est ça qui nous rend qui fait
un peu notre force budget
en sportif accompli kelis rock parfois
les baskets de breakdance pour les
crampons il évolue comme milieu droit
dans l'équipe de voisins-le-bretonneux
depuis septembre c'est vraiment un sport
qui me plaisent j'aime bien la vitesse
tout ce qui est jeu technique et ce que
j'aime surtout c'est d'esprit d'équipé
surtout quand on va le mieux une fois
encore kelis n'est pas seule sa famille
au bord du terrain pour l'encourager on
laisse vraiment tout le temps quotidien
après on lui parle aussi de de se
détendre un peu à côté de pas que penser
à ça parce que après sinon ça fonctionne
pas donc on est vraiment là au quotidien
peu importe skis à voile rendez vous le
18 novembre sur la piste de danse de
liévin dans le pas de calais pour les
championnats de france de break dance
kelis blessé l'année dernière a hâte
d'affronter ses adversaires
[Musique]
ap